i want to talk about um
the mental health of being a trader
because you know being a trader is
a great job in terms of the money you make but
there's a darker side to that sometimes you know
you know i remember
on the trading floor people become traders because
they want to make money you know what i mean
and i became a trader because
i wanted to make money and
it's almost all men on these training floors
or at least it was when i worked there
and there's so much like ambition and
so much determination to be successful
and so much drive but to be honest like a lot
of the time what people want is they just want
drive they want success they want money they don't
really care how they make it and um it can drive
men into like such a competitive space you
know what i mean like there was this one time
when i just first started as a trader like i was
getting to know the traders on the desk and um
one of the guys on my team he took me out drinking
one evening and he went out late late into the
evening and it got to like 1AM and i was like i
gotta go home and we used to start work at 7 in
the morning you know i was like i want to go home
and he was like no stay out stay at mine you know
we can have like a big night and i stayed out we
stayed up all night and by the time i got to work
i was absolutely smashed like i was like super
hungover i went to the bathroom and i threw up
and then my boss sent me home and i was like oh
my god i'm gonna get fired but i came in super
early the next day and then my boss came in and
he said to me about the senior trader i went out
with he said did that guy do that to you last
night and i just laughed i didn't say anything
then the senior trader came in and the
boss the first thing he said to him was
Gary said you did that to him and then this guy
right i remember at the time i used to sit on the
edge of the desk and there was an empty seat to
the next of me and beyond that was this guy who
i went out with and he was like in his early 30s
he was a big guy he played rugby right big guy
right and um i was sitting there doing my work
on a computer and i turn around and look at him
the guy was looking at me straight in my face like
this and he was growling like a wolf like this*grrr grrr*
and then under the desk was like was the computer
but they were behind like a pair of doors and he
was growling and he was kicking these doors *BAM*
like that on the training floor you know what i mean
and that's when i realized like man there's some
crazy guys in this space you know what i mean like
but this same guy i remember my very first day
at work i went to have lunch from the canteen,
had lunch, come back and he said to me where
have you been i said I've been to the canteen
he said I've worked here for 12 years i never once
had lunch with a canteen we eat lunch on the desk
that was on my first day there right and i see
like they're trying to sort of haze you into a
space where you feel like your responsibility is
there have to be on the desk, have to be all the
time and like when you're working on the trading
floor there's all these sounds there's all these
noises going off and like at 12:30 whatever
inflation for the UK is coming out and then 13:30
employment date for the US is coming out
the guy would turn up behind me and be like
what was the US inflation data? and it had just
come out one minute before you know what i mean
and you're like **** i don't know i don't know and
you feel like you have to know you have to know
like and you you get into this situation where you
start to feel like you need to know every single
thing that's happening all the time you know
what i mean and when you become a big trader
like you've got these trades running for your book
all the time all the time you have to check them
people will book wrong trades into your book to
try and take money off you have to check them
you have to go and get the money back you start to
feel like you're surrounded by wolves in a sense
and i remember this one time eventually when
i was becoming a really successful trader i
was able to hire my own junior trader and i
hired this young guy Italian guy a nice guy
and he was my junior in 2011 which was the year
that i became the most profitable trader in the
bank and you know he thought that i was, that was
great because he was a junior for the most profitable
trader in the bank you know what i mean but he
was quite critical of me sometimes and he said
to me listen Gary i think you're a great trader
but you've got a problem with your personality
which is your too homo homini lupus that's
what he said and i was like what the?
homo homini lupus? He goes homo homini lupus
is Latin it means a man is wolf to man
and i was like what do you mean what are you
talking about he goes you think you're surrounded
by wolves you think everyone is a wolf and i said
look at this place look at where you are look at
the people around you i think i'm surrounded
by wolves because i am surrounded by wolves
and then i think in hindsight that's probably a
sign that he was exactly right his criticism of
what he was saying you know what i mean but um you
know i loved my time on the trading floor in some
senses i worked with some amazing people i learned
so much about economics about how the world works
but i definitely internalize this sense that the
world is full of wolves and people are out to get
you people are out to take your money and it's a
competition and that in turn this understanding
that the world is full of wolves that fed the
wolf inside of me and in a sense i became a wolf
and i was out there to take other people's
money on the floor you know what i mean
and i was out there to be the best myself you know
i mean that year 2011 when i made a lot of money
i was working with another trader who was
much older he was already a very rich guy
and um he wasn't on the desk a lot he
would go out you know he'd go out drinking
you know and this and then one time he lost a lot
of money while he was off the desk and that year
i was making a lot of money and he thought that
i should give him money back and i was like nah
it's not happening you know what i mean because
for me it was just about me and my space and
my money and i was making that money to get
my family out of the ghetto you know i mean
but what i want to talk about is that drive
that drives us as young men to be successful
and how powerful it can be but also how
damaging it can be that it can become
completely all-consuming and suddenly you can
start viewing other people as purely competition
and then that can just destroy your own mental
health because ultimately we are social creatures
and we need to be able to trust one another and if
we can't do that then we're not going to be happy
and i remember after the end of 2011 and that
was the year i was the best trader in the bank
in early 2012 i got my bonus and like in the
second half of 2011 all i could think about
was this bonus because this is like winning
the lottery you know it's going to take me
and my family it's going to change my life
my family's life for all of the whole future
and then i was obsessed with getting this
bonus getting this bonus is all i cared about
and then in the beginning of 2012 it happened
i got the bonus um and it was so much money
it's gonna change my life you know but i didn't
feel happy at all the first thing i thought was
i have to make this money secure i have to make
sure it's all well invested i have to make it
safe that's all i thought about it didn't give me
no joy and i went back home and i pulled open my
computer and i had all my paperwork and i got all
my spreadsheets out and i was like thinking this
money is going to go here that money's going to
go there like it's all going to be secure and then
the girl who i was seeing at the time she was
a fantastic girl and she come to my house and
and then she saw me there sitting in the corner
doing all my paper doing all my spreadsheets
and she said um what you doing and i said um well
i'm you know i'm doing all my spreadsheets i've
got to figure out how to invest this money and
she was like oh you seem pretty stressed and i
was like of course i'm stressed it's a lot of
money this is important you know what i mean
and then she said to me if i made
as much money as what you just made
the last thing i'll be doing is sitting in
the corner of my living room stressing out
and um i realized she was obviously
she was right she was right that um
the money it wasn't making me happy it was
just pulling me away from where i came from
and the people that i grew up with and from
everything that i knew and all it was doing was
giving me stress but at the same time i totally
understand that it's that money that gives me the
power to do what i'm doing now to devote my life
and my time to trying to talk about economics and
trying to talk about inequality so it's
a flip side of it but what i'm saying is
i don't want to live in a world where you have
to choose you know where the only way to get the
freedom to do meaningful work is to like make
a crazy amount of money i wanna live in a world
where ordinary people can get enough money
from ordinary jobs that if they want to take
some time out to do meaningful work they can you
know i mean i don't want to live in a world where
i have to choose between being an ordinary person
and having financial security i want to be an
ordinary person and have financial security i want
to have financial security and live in the world
with other people that come from where i'm from
with financial security you know so that's what
i'm saying well that's why i do the work that i do
because i want i know that we can have that kind
of world we can have a world where ordinary people
can get financial security i'm not saying it's
going to be a paradise but we can make an economy
where ordinary people if they're willing to work
and get financial security we had that 50 years
ago we had that 60 years ago i don't want to be
in a space where my kids are in my situation where
they have to choose either to live in this like
niche world of wealthy people that don't know the
real world or to struggle you know what i'm saying
but yeah the last i wanted to add on this
subject of mental health is that like um
i was very successful by the metrics of the
way a lot of people view success for men
i made a lot of money you know i had a
beautiful girlfriend i had a nice apartment
but i struggled in a lot of ways um it was
really difficult for me quitting my job and
like i felt really separated from where i came
from and the people that i knew um so when i
see young men out there struggling struggling
hard to make money to make money to make money
i understand it because it was me and i did it
but um i also want those people to realize that
money alone is not happiness and there's so many
other things which are important and which people
should be grateful for like friendship and like
family um and i wish we didn't live in a world
where it was so difficult just to get that
basic amount of money you need to feel safe
and i totally understand people are going
to push and push and push till they get that
but at the same time i want people to understand
that the world that we live in is unfair and it's
difficult and there's a lot of luck involved to
be honest and if you are not making as much money
as you want that doesn't mean you're a failure you
know i come from a poor family and i don't look up
to anyone more than i look up to my dad because he
worked every day and he gave us what we needed and
even though he was poor the biggest problems in
my life was never about money you know what i mean
the most important thing is having a
happiness having that secure family around you
but when you do go through difficult
times like i did i think the most
important thing is to remember that you're not
surrounded by wolves even if you think you are
there will be people around you who will
be willing to just be there and support you
and if you feel that there's no one
there right now then someone will come
and um when those people are there it's
really important to reach out to them i
think that's the thing that's gonna keep
you sane in the difficult times and um
when things get really really difficult and
you can't reach out and feel that you can't
the most important thing to do at that time is
to just hold on until things get better because
they will like when you hit the bottom you
can't go further you can only bounce back up
and if you reach a point where you
feel that you you can't hold on
that's the time when you really have to hold
on and that's what's going to determine like
that's what's going to turn you into
a man i think if you can do that
you cannot be surprised when these people turn
to crime and these people turn to dangerous means
of getting it if the best people were in the best
jobs then they've come from all throughout society
but right now they all come from the
same schools and the same families